ladies and gentlemen
brie larson apparently sucks and the
internet doesn't like her
what this is news when did that happen
news room is just such a well-received
movie did we get 100k dislikes just now
oh probably
saying that sarcastically i thought
captain marvel was all right
the video's blocked worldwide
this really intrigues me it's just so
fascinating
over a hundred k fans dislike brie
larson
on youtube yeah according to the report
all
hundred thousand people watched the
video
in its entirety and then voted on
whether or not
they liked the video and each of them
left a very measured comment breaking
down exactly
why they disliked so you know it's all
valid definitely 100
no flippant activity here let's break
down this article
the recent brie larson youtube video
posted near two weeks ago has over a
hundred
hundred k dislikes as fans voiced their
dissent for the captain
marvel actress it'll be fun as if we go
through some of the top comments
the 30 year old will do that after this
the 30 year old recently launched a
youtube channel with the obvious help
of a public relations team and a full
production team which led to backlash
not only from fans but from fellow
youtubers as well
i'm not familiar with the fellow
youtubers getting mad
this is all important news people
california's shut down again
within mere hours of posting her video
so i made a decision
the number of dislikes started to
skyrocket are now over a hundred
seven thousand at the time of recording
this and i did watch the video
it's at 110k upvotes and 109k
downvotes so the thousands and thousands
of comments on the video over
76k are also filled with fans
criticizing larson we'll go through the
top comments later i'm sure that's what
this article is pulling from in the
video brie larson jokes about how she is
new to youtube
yet her video is produced with the same
professional quality as a hollywood
project in all fairness
it's produced the same professional
quality as a
hollywood project that is working via
zoom all right
yeah i mean it's not like a full-on like
ooh dolly shots
and cranes you know just to be fair here
now granted it's pretty high production
quality i i must say
especially in terms of how it's edited i
don't think she edited herself she
definitely did
she loves to edit or she did edit
herself and that's why it's taking her
so long to do a follow-up video it's all
just a vlog about her editing style so
she can prove to us the authenticity the
last one took me two months to figure
out how to edit on imovie you're
happy now i use none of the pro
equipment
this is the place to talk about things
that are important and that matter she
says it doesn't matter that there
isn't also silly content that there's a
way for me to express myself personally
but there will also be deep
conversations
anti-racist rhetoric inclusive content
of course
as you'd expect fans viewers
correction viewers waited until they got
to that statement before they hit the
down vote
we don't like that anti-racist rhetoric
coming from
you brie larson not after you ruined our
marvels
larson or her production team have yet
to post a second video to youtube but
brie larson did most recently
update her social media accounts with
the cover of be all right by ariana
grande i haven't listened to that yet i
don't follow her on instagram
oh you're missing i need to get around
so many likes
positive comments she's lucky there's
not a down vote or not she is
the actress also doesn't come without
additional controversy as rumors offer
she doesn't get along with the avengers
cast and that disney is losing
confidence in her portrayal of captain
marvel
let's go through some of these top
comments and then we'll share some
opinions here
so her pin comment is give me all the
ideas what do you want to see and who
should i collab with
oh i don't i don't know if i want to go
through the
489 replies i think the first reply is
very very on the mark
so the top comment though resh my spidey
sense is tingling and i think the
comment section will be disabled in
future videos
i don't think she should do that if
anything that just opens up
more dislikes it just shows that you
noticed it it shows
that it doesn't really do anything to it
it's like a non-win
situation where it shows that they got
to you they can't do it
the same way again but you know that
anger will just boil over someplace else
right from a person who you know runs a
youtube channel i always see the
temptation
in doing it especially if your videos
getting a lot of hate you know
i i know the temptation in doing it but
i also know that it just welcomes
more and more vitriol with the dislike
button and this will only just
the people who really hate her will find
different ways of going after her via
social media or some [ __ ] like that
you know there's always some way
someone who has too much time on their
hands will be like
i gotta find her on twitter and message
her directly i feel like
half of her views are people checking to
see how many dislikes she has
i bet that's true i bet that's a hundred
percent true
that's why i clicked on it i'm being
honest i had no interest in watching
this video
it's got 10 seconds of watch time for
brie larson
and here's where this is that's
interesting actually oh man the upvote
down bow gap is closing youtube is
slacking
erasing down boats i've heard about this
i've heard
first this is what got me curious to
check out this video like if you go down
how did the dislikes lower from 108k to
104k
i'd like to believe 4 000 people watched
the video
was like stop it that would be nice
i would i would have a bit more faith in
humanity if that were to happen
is there a scandal about youtube like
literally going in and tinkering or is
this one of those things where like if
you check at a certain time the numbers
don't always like you know the real-time
views
usually for like corporate
stuff it can happen i've heard that
happen kind of with the last of us too
i'm sure they can do it i'm sure they
can based off these thumbnails and the
recommended
maybe the youtubers who are talking
about like going after her might be the
quartering
and geeks and gamers because based off
what they look positive those are the
people going after her
you would have never expected never when
what what
so out of character now in terms of the
video itself did you ever
watch this video i am such a huge brie
larson fan
i have watched it definitely yes
so many times crap if i even
watched it what's the gist of the actual
video most of it
really heavily edited where it's a a
wide
variety of interviews you got sean from
uh
oh first week fees from hot ones yeah
you got him who's featured in here
briefly
lilly singh as well but it these
interviews
it's like clips really of her just
pretty much being like i'm starting a
youtube channel what advice do you have
and it's super fast like the way
everything's really edited and then she
know she gives some a little bit of
commentary like if it's bookended
here with some commentary but it's
mainly that this is like big clip
compilation her getting advice you know
be yourself
be sincere post a workout video like a
whole bunch of stuff okay
this video could have been worse it
could have been um a whole bunch of
people
uh saying they take responsibility
it's black and white oh people were
trying they're
they're they're you know doing what they
can to help the society
should have been people singing she
could have been yeah singing imagine or
something like that
i i ca i don't think the video is by any
stretch a terrible video
i don't think it's a bad video i think
there's a little bit of like
hollywood cringe to it but it's not to
the degree where i would
be like oh this is the most embarrassing
humiliating thing on the planet i by no
means
share that feeling i don't mind brie
larson i don't love free larsen
i have no qualms with her the way though
the rest of the internet seems to really
hate her
i mean she really love her captain
marvel but i love some of the other work
she's done so
like in terms of my brie larson stance
i'm about as neutral as it gets
yeah likewise i do think there's a bit
of an eye-opening thing here you know
it's easy to chalk up a lot of like
you know the vocal minority can be
pretty loud when it comes to breathing
when it comes to certain
things or people but the fact that this
vid this video just went
live and then was instantly hit
with so this is about a 50 50 ratio
right now
assuming youtube did not delete any
dislikes
51.49 right now i guess the internet
really freaking hates brie larson
i mean yes there's 110 000 people who
clearly care enough maybe there are
people who like her maybe there are
people who love her but just don't
really care about like this youtube
channel or don't care about her social
media stuff
and just don't get involved anything
with brie larson online
and so we're not hearing from them you
know well and i have to believe that the
people
who are you know up in arms about
captain marvel are probably more apt to
find her on youtube than the people who
just thought room was a great movie
captain marvel has done a lot to her
public image and some of this
just like everything surrounding that
time her coming out and talking about
critics and stuff like that and the
ratio of representation and i don't know
man i feel like maybe she's had the
misfortune of just not quite
articulating her point properly or
something because yeah i don't know what
would have happened
captain marvel was just fine and we
didn't have any of that controversy of
her making statements about
you know the critics and whatnot i don't
know if this is just bless you
100 of the world's you know view on her
but
here on youtube i'm absolutely not
surprised that this is the response just
because this is you know
one of the hubs and havens for the kind
of people that she pisses off
generally speaking and also too i mean i
do get
some of the ire in that this is part of
a wave of
celebrities who are hopping on youtube
making the most out of that when they
don't have to try the same way that you
know
youtubers do yeah it's like the video
is is cringe in it in a different way
because if it was any other celebrity
this wouldn't be a big deal unless it
was like ruby rose or some [ __ ]
you know but but if it was any other
celebrity this wouldn't be
it really wouldn't be the video it
itself i think the the cringe part to me
comes from a youtuber's dance
of it feels like an insanely long
channel trailer
as opposed to a first video
i mean just that's where my cringe comes
from with it i could
i can imagine that i mean just looking
at the timestamp and listening to what
you've told me it sounds like this is
the pilot for a reality show
that's gonna take place on youtube that
will have some kind of you know oh this
is gonna be in the youtube
format but it'll be you know review uh
interviews and variety
and you know well like look i'm gonna
just skip around for john look at that
it changes like a famous person
well i don't know who any of these
[ __ ] people are to be totally honest
and like i see it all these days like i
don't know what these people are changes
up
like every 10 to 30 seconds there's a
there's a there's a different
it's like cutting around all these
people yeah for advice
i guess my biggest question is was this
her idea or was this something that like
her team thought would be a good idea to
rehabilitate her public image for the
youth
or something like as much as i have the
most neutral stance on brie larson
there's a part of me
she's officially i mean she's she's
she's she's made a lot of money and
she's doing fine like she's made that
marvel music no matter what in terms of
her career
she's doing well and she'll make those
moral residuals no matter what
but in terms of the youtube world
not that she needs to succeed here she
has she has no reason
really to she's in an underdog position
right now
and so i would love it if her content in
it of itself
was able to have people go you know what
i hated this i hated her idea but now
that i've been watching some of her
videos and other people
just won't ever give her the chance
right yeah people of life like a big
majority
probably won't um the people who already
hate her i
think this could also be a cool way for
her to like bounce back in some way
in terms of this video because what's
fascinating to me she was on hot ones
and that got like over 2 million views
granted the dislikes on it are higher
than usual for that show
but they're nowhere near these needs
well you know you got the show itself
taking the edge off and she's also like
you know making jokes and she gets very
personal in it and i've only seen like
maybe
70 of the video i haven't finished it
but she gets very
personal in that video as well like that
like the great thing about that show is
that they're some of the best interviews
you'll ever see
that you really get to know her and yet
that has like
a really good liked dislike ratio yeah
yeah
it's considered the fact that it's brie
larson you know what i feel like
that seems to be like the best thing
that this could do because everyone's
big complaint about captain marvel was
like oh she doesn't have a personality i
can't connect to her i just hate this
character and so yeah
like especially judging by things like
that hot ones episode she does have the
charisma she can clearly be
fun and playful and you know open and
deep and whatever and so i feel like
yeah a youtube channel of her own would
be a terrific place to
establish and just illustrate that if it
sounds like it could maybe get out of
its own way or something or maybe
maybe be a little more off the cuff
maybe a little more diy or something
like that to take away that sheen that
creates the barrier there well we'll see
we'll see
oh guys do you hate brie larson
you're gonna give her a chance do you
hate us because we don't hate brilliance
i mean you know me if i loved her i'd
i'd do my best to defend her
she's cool i'm fine with brie larson i
don't really have a one way or the other
it's just so weird to see all this
vitriol for one human being and i'm
always like i'm whatever better
that's probably the most care i have is
just like i don't think this person
deserves the level of hate they receive
so i guess i like you
at least until you know everything evens
out and things get fair again
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that notification bell
last but not least who is the lucky
adelia chamberlain speaking of the kind
of injustices that bree larson stands up
for and i can't remember if you actually
like captain marvel or not but you are a
big marvel girl i don't know that much i
felt it was appropriate to shout you out
in this video and this time's a
quarantine i don't want to get too
personal even though i've seen you
posted some stuff on twitter about it
but that's your
choosing i am sorry for the
living situation that you currently have
to go through the kind
of thoughts and influences that are in
your surroundings
as you try to lead a more positive life
i know how difficult
that can be however i do want to say
with what you're surrounded by i think
it's
awesome i think it's beautiful that you
have managed to turn into
the sympathetic empathetic
understanding enormously caring
human being that you are today despite
the environment that you were around
because most people just become a
product of that and you became a product
that ended up on the
opposite side it's giving you this level
of
passion so as shitty of a situation as
it can be where you're at
at the same time it has made you into a
stronger sharper and more intelligent
person
that i am privileged to know thank you
for being you
i love you and stay strong
and get a gun and murder
oh no murder everyone
you can be the new captain marvel there
you go